the gui programming environment of sas
contains six main windows
the project designer window shows the
hierarchical structure and process flow
of a project and all of its modules
the project explorer window is similar
to the project designer window but the
display of project structure is in a
drop-down format
the code editor window contains the
written code
in this window we can write and edit our
codes
the server list shows the actual
location where the data will be saved
the log window contains the execution
summary of a code and also lists errors
if any
the output window displays the output of
the executed code
let's move on to discuss the sas program
sas program is a set of instructions
used to access manage analyze or
represent the data
you can combine different data sets of
sas instructions to accomplish your
requirements
an sas program may have a data step or
procedure step or a combination of both
in the next screen we will discuss these
two steps in detail
data steps are used to create or modify
sas data sets
we can use data steps to insert data
into an sas data set
a data set is nothing but data holders
in sas
we will talk about them in detail in the
forthcoming screens
the data step is also used to compute
the data stored
it checks and corrects errors in the
data
it also creates new data sets by merging
and updating existing data sets
proc or procedure steps are predefined
routines that enable us to analyze and
process the data in an sas data set
they also help in representing the data
in the form of a report
we can use proc steps to create a report
based on stored data and produce
descriptive statistics
we can also use proc steps to create a
summary report on the stored data
proc steps are also used to produce
plots and charts for data analysis
in the next screen we will talk about
the basic layout for an sas program